je m'appelle maria da aparecida
Je suis un chanteur brésilien et j'ai eu le
grand plaisir de chanter récemment à
opéra de paris
carmen dit mais ce soir je suis là
parmi vous pour chanter une mélodie de
mon brésil de waldemar henrique tamba
jeu tajá parce que la plupart des
matin elle se donne entre le nœud qui s'est passé
ce matin et encore l'après midi
la peur d'un brésil qui veut encore hier
c'est que tu profites pleinement
alors coince-moi mais
que mon amour me veut bien
et certains ton amour sera plus le même
personne qui est à moi je donne trop de nero
personne ne lit
si indien revendiqué rouler sans tibia
libéré à la gomme
déjà à la mort porte ainsi notre
amour
seulement de l'eau
jeu de bataille cadeau
aussi au combat
duh une bataille je pense déjà mon amour
Amy veut le groupe
et ton amour
être sous la mienne de personne d'autre
mon o'dowd oman personne d'autre
la botte déjà o hey je pense que c'est féminin a so o
Indien a porté son buisson libéré à la gomme
c'était pour la mort
alors porte notre amour la fille
alors démarrez maintenant
oh si avantageux
ah